dozens of journalists in washington
gathering near the offices of al jazeera
on wednesday to mourn the loss of one of
their own shireen abu akley a colleague
they loved for her friendship and
admired for her work
work that is respected at the highest
levels of the u.s government now the
biden administration is condemning
shireen's killing an american citizen
and calling for an investigation and
prosecution of those responsible
it is important to us it is important to
the world
that that investigation be thorough that
it be comprehensive that it be
transparent and importantly
that investigations end with full
accountability and those responsible for
her death being held responsible for
their actions on capitol hill where the
most powerful member of the u.s house of
representatives met with jordan's king
abdullah nancy pelosi called the killing
a horrific tragedy adding the congress
is committed to the defense of press
freedoms worldwide
people woke up to the killing of shireen
abu eklah on the floor
palestinian-american member of congress
rashida talib called for a moment of
silence earlier she tweeted shireen abu
ah was murdered by a government that
receives unconditional funding by our
country with zero accountability
indeed the security relationship between
the u.s and israel stretches back for
decades with each year billions in
unconditional security assistance
provided the irony one of those weapons
paid for by u.s taxpayers could
ultimately be found responsible for the
death of an american
last month at the white house
correspondents association
dinner an evening dedicated to honoring
journalism u.s president joe biden said
the rights of journalists to do their
jobs must be protected the prefresh is
not the enemy to people
far from it
at your best
your guardians of the truth
president biden is set to travel to
israel next month no details of his trip
have been released on friday he will sit
down in the oval office with king
abdullah of jordan
two agenda items now about to become
more complex
in light of the death of shireen abu
akley
kimberly helkid al jazeera the white
house